i believe in the power of a job to be a
meaningful pathway forward for somebody
all i need is for society to give me a
chance
coming here
it has made my life
amazing it really has not only do i love
the chicken i love the job i got really
compelled by this idea of what
supportive meaningful employment can
mean to members of our community that
have faced adversity
[Music]
hot chicken takeover is a restaurant
chain born right here in the midwest
that sells delicious nashville style hot
chicken in an atmosphere that's really
reminiscent of a family reunion hot
chicken takeover officially started in
2014. there was a little window that
this window is modeled after my wife was
the only cashier i was the only host and
we had friends back in the kitchen like
helping us figure out like how in the
hell to start a company
and so i was really excited about it as
an opportunity but for me as an
entrepreneur i was a lot more interested
in the opportunity to become an employer
again hot chicken just became kind of
the means to that end
having a business that justifies
employees is a huge privilege in my mind
i spent over a decade just trying to
find ideas that could allow me to create
supportive work opportunities to members
of our community that have faced
adversity
i've been committed to fair chance
employment for some time now and
ultimately it's because fair chance
employment is an equitable opportunity
to give somebody access to work that's
generally been cut out of the work
environment there are an entire series
of industries and employers that are
really unwilling to give them fair
consideration for work the majority of
employees that have joined our team at
hot chicken have experienced adversity
tied to the impacts of homelessness the
justice system
my name is kevin fischer and i was in
prison for 26 years doing that much time
and coming out here
a lot of society that's all we can hire
you because of that it was very hard you
know i went to the parole board they
deemed me to be fit for society all i
need is for society give me a chance
when we think about recruitment we are a
little bit more unconventional sure we
do active postings online but
additionally we build a deep sense of
partnership with community agencies
whether they're social service agencies
emergency housing providers recovery
programming that ultimately are engaged
with the community of folks out there
that
could benefit from fair chance
consideration we're often kind of
anecdotally seeing team members that
needed fair chance consideration rising
at a faster rate within the company and
with a much deeper commitment to our
company values and the support of their
peers kevin has been a part of many new
restaurant openings from his time in our
market
[Applause]
let's started out as a crew member and
worked my way up in three and a half
years everybody had problems in life you
know as you never know what a person is
going through from one day to the other
you make a person smile it could be the
littlest thing
and it means a whole whole lot and
that's what i want to give to
the employees that i give direction to
if you got a problem if i can help you
with it i'm there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we desperately believe that personal
stability and professional stability are
hand-in-hand while we have 401ks we also
have programs that are focused on match
savings and matched milestones access to
banking services access to financial
literacy programming all of those things
are hyper-relevant benefits that make an
impact in somebody's life
but also increase their personal
stability we see it not just as
our desired intent for the business but
also a really competitive piece of our
business model and our labor strategy
fair chance employment is a critical
piece of that puzzle every single one of
these restaurants to me is you know 25
to 35 positions several salaries more
career opportunities and advancement we
feel like we're just getting started we
have an opportunity to expand our brand
to become kind of a best in category
restaurant concept i do believe it's
replicable we just opened a location in
new york city
and we're expanding quite a bit and so
that's a little bit about how chicken
tacos what i hope is that uh companies
that do invest in this work see the
value and the stay in power of treating
their workforces particularly
entry-level workforces with more equity
and dignity than they perhaps have
before